le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
oui
pour la majorité des jeunes qu'ils aient
fait des études ou pas il est difficile
de trouver un travail
60 % des moins de 25 ans sont frappés
par le chômage à la réunion
le manque d'expérience est un argument
très utilisé par les employeurs pour
refuser une embauche
certains jeunes qualifiés sont parfois
obligés d'accepter un travail qui n'est
pas en rapport avec leurs études ou
leurs ambitions
alors qui peut les aider à avoir de
l'expérience professionnelle
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
delphine est une jeune femme de 25 ans
et c'est d'un pas volontaire et motivée
qu'elle commence sa journée de travail
delphine est hôtesse d'accueil au muséum
d'histoire naturelle située au jardin de
l'état à saint denis
chaque jour elle est chargée d'inspecter
les lieux pour voir si tout est en ordre
afin de recevoir au mieux les visiteurs
avant d'avoir ce poste delphine était
agent d'entretien avec des contrats
aidés renouvelables en tant que femme et
maman responsable
elle était toujours dans la crainte de
perdre son emploi
une situation instable et difficile à
vivre au quotidien
aujourd'hui dans ce nouveau travail
elle bénéficie d'un contrat emplois
d'avenir
ce dispositif soutenu par le conseil
général garantit un contrat d'un an
renouvelable deux fois au maximum
pour delphine ce contrat lui permet de
prévoir un peu mieux son avenir proche
mais aussi d'acquérir de l'expérience
professionnelle
j'ai donc ça après bien connaître le
musée aussi j'habite bien la réunion
mais je connaissais pas tout ce qu'ils
avaient dans le musée mais maintenant
j'apprends même mois pour moi c'est une
grande chance parce que comme c'est
difficile d'avoir un contrat indéterminé
un compte à 3 ans à ça moi j'aime bien
les choses
aunis et ou moins à 25 ans avec un
enfant donc ça aide bien là avant
j'étais agent d'entretien mais c'était
un contrat aidé qui était de six mois à
chaque fois renouvelable et que ça n'a
pas aller plus loin d'un an
on peut pas grand-chose faire grand
chose avec ce contrat et indiqué qu'un
contrat d'avenir on oppose beaucoup de
projets aussi c'est à dire au
financement personnellement et voilà ce
qui dieu la vie qu'on a besoin
maintenant je vois que tout ça baisse ça
m'aide aussi avoir ses besoins la belle
a pour l'instant après trois ans je sais
pas qu'est ce que je vais faire mais
j'espère que tu es là dedans si on me
donne la possibilité grâce au dispositif
emplois d'avenir soutenu par le conseil
général
750 jeunes dans les services du
département comme delphine ou dans des
ligues et comités sportifs ou encore
dans des entreprises pour peuvent déjà
s'épanouir
ils peuvent avoir des projets d'avenir
et acquérir une expérience de qualité
tous ces avantages leur permettront
d'affronter le monde du travail avec
beaucoup plus de sérénité et de vécu ils
auront les clés pour aller au bout de
leurs ambitions et pourront faire des
entretiens d'embauché avec dans leurs
bagages une véritable expérience
professionnelle
nous accompagnons les jeunes réunionnais
pour qu ils réussissent leurs études à
travers donc les aides sur les bourses
départementales et ses jeunes diplômés
enfin on essaie également au travers le
dispositif des emplois d'avenir de leur
donner le pouce nécessaire pour que
pendant trois ans les et une formation
accompagné d'un tuteur du conseil
général pour que ce soit un tremplin
pour eux et qu'ils puissent au fond
construire un cursus et un parfois
professionnelle le chômage que tout le
monde pas seulement les jeunes mais nous
essayons au travers le dispositif des
emplois d'avenir d'accompagner la
jeunesse réunionnaise et le projet du
conseil général qui est l'ambition
jeunesse pour les prochaines veille
pour encourager et soutenir la jeunesse
réunionnaise dans le monde du travail
le conseil général s'est engagé à
recruter ou aider au recrutement 750
contrats emplois d'avenir à travers ces
embauches
le conseil général offre à la jeunesse
réunionnaise un sentiment de soutien le
monde du travail est de plus en plus
difficile les plaçant de plus en plus
rare et le chômage augmente chaque année
à la réunion
c'est une réalité qu'il faut affronter
le département en est bien conscient et
continue de soutenir les réunionnais en
apportant de l'aide et des solutions
il est important que les jeunes qui
feront la réunion de demain évolue dans
une ambiance solidaire qui doit se
transmettre dans les générations à venir
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais